>> Jesse: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
I'M JESSE WATTERS IN FOR.
THE LEFT STILL IN A COMPLETE
MELTDOWN OVER GLENN YOUNGKIN'S
WIN IN VIRGINIA.
THEY ARE ACCUSING EVERYONE WHO
VOTED FOR HIM OF BEING A TIKI
TORCH-CARRYING WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
BUT FIRST, DONALD TRUMP BECAME
THE NOMINEE FOR PRESIDENT IN
MID-JULY 2016.
JUST DAYS LATER, A RUSSIAN
NATIONAL LIVING IN THIS COUNTRY
MADE A CLAIM THAT WOULD UPEND
DONALD TRUMP'S CANDIDACY AND
EVENTUALLY HIS PRESIDENCY.
IT IS A CLAIM THAT CHANGE THE
COURSE OF U.S. POLITICS FOR THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS.
THE RUSSIAN NATIONAL, A MAN
NAMED IGOR DENCH AND GO, SAID HE
HAD JUST RECEIVED A PHONE
CALL PROVING THAT DONALD TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN WAS CONSPIRING WITH THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
THE PHONE CALL SUPPOSEDLY CAME
FROM U.S. CITIZEN SERVING AS
PRESIDENT OF THE
RUSSIAN-AMERICAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
THAT ALLEGED PHONE CALL BECAME
THE CENTRAL PIECE OF EVIDENCE IN
THE STEELE DOSSIER, WRITTEN BY
BRITISH EX-SPY WRISTER FOR
STEEL.
THAT DOSSIER IN TURN WAS A KEY
PIECE OF EVIDENCE IN THE FBI'S
WARRANT APPLICATIONS TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
SUPPOSEDLY SECRET WARRANT
APPLICATIONS TO THE MEDIA AND
THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION NARRATIVE
BEGAN.
IN JANUARY, BUZZFEED PUBLISHED
THE STEELE DOSSIER ONLINE.
THEY JUSTIFIED PUBLISHING THE
DOCUMENT BY SAYING THE FBI WAS
SUPPOSEDLY TAKING IT SERIOUSLY.
>> THIS DOCUMENT THAT IS BEING
FOUGHT OVER -- BY THE WAY,
EVERYBODY EXCEPT THE PUBLIC IN A
CERTAIN SENSE HAS SEEN, WE HAVE
SEEN, AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
SPECIAL POWERS.
WE CAN SEE THIS, TOO, AND WE CAN
DEAL WITH THE FACT THAT IT IS
CLEARLY LABELED AND OUT THERE,
CLEARLY LABELED THAT SOME THINGS
IN IT ARE UNTRUE, WHICH IS WHAT
WE DID.
>> I GET IT.
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS BECAUSE
FAMOUS PEOPLE ARE GOSSIPING
ABOUT IT AND BECAUSE OTHER --
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, GARDEN-VARIETY --
>> THEY GOSSIP, TOO.
>> NOT GOSSIP, INITIAL
BRIEFINGS, PUBLIC DOCUMENTS
UNDER THE FREEDOM OF INFORMATION
LAW.
>> ACTUALLY, IN SOME SENSE IT I.
WHAT YOU REPORTED WAS NOT TRUE.
>> Rachel:
>> Jesse: STUFFER STEEL WAS
WORKING FOR AN OPPOSITION
RESEARCH FIRM COLDFUSION GPS,
WHICH WAS FUNDED BY THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
IT STATED THAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WAS WORKING WITH
HACKERS IN THE RUSSIAN CONSULATE
IN MIAMI BUT THERE IS NO RUSSIAN
CONSULATE IN MIAMI BUT FOR
PARTISAN REASONS, MEDIA
PERSONALITIES LOOKED OVER THAT
AND INSISTED THE DOSSIER WAS
RELIABLE.
>> THE ALLEGATIONS IN THE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE DOSSIER, AND
YOU WENT THROUGH THE TIMELINE
VERY WELL A FEW MOMENTS AGO, OUR
STUNNING.
>> THERE ARE SUBSTANTIAL
PORTIONS OF WHAT WAS IN THE
STEELE DOSSIER, WHICH WAS A RAW
INTELLIGENCE DOCUMENT THAT HAS
INDEED CHECKED OUT.
>> BASED ON OUR OWN REPORTING
AND WORD FROM OFFICIAL SOURCES,
THE DOSSIER IS FAR FROM BOGUS.
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO STOP
CALLING IT THE BOGUS DOSSIER,
INCREASINGLY IT IS THE ACCURATE
DOSSIER.
>> Jesse: THANKS TO AN
INDICTMENT FROM JOHN DURHAM, WE
KNOW THE TRUTH.
THERE WAS NO LEAKED PHONE CALL
FROM SUE IGOR DEMCHENKO.
HE WAS NOT SPEAKING TO THE HEAD
OF THE RUSSIAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
ABOUT ANYTHING AT ALL.
INSTEAD, ACCORDING TO TODAY'S
INDICTMENT, THE SOURCE OF MUCH
OF DEMCHENKO'S INFORMATION WAS A
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OPERATIVE.
AND A FORMER HILLARY CLINTON
ADVISOR.
WE CAN IDENTIFY THAT CLINTON
ADVISOR TONIGHT.
HIS NAME IS CHARLES DOLAND.
IN OTHER WORDS,
HILLARY CLINTON'S TEAM WAS NOT
JUST FUNDING THE STEELE DOSSIER,
THEY WERE EFFECTIVELY WRITING
IT, TOO.
DOLAND, BY THE WAY, HAS
EXTENSIVE CONNECTIONS TO RUSSIA,
CLOSER THAN ANYBODY ON
DONALD TRUMP'S TEAM HAD FROM
2006 TO 2014.
FOR EXAMPLE, DOLAND DID P.R.
WORK ON BEHALF OF THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT AND A RUSSIAN ENERGY
COMPANY.
ACCORDING TO DURHAM'S
INDICTMENT, DEMCHENKO TOLD
DOLAND HE WAS WORKING ON "A
PROJECT AGAINST TRUMP."
DOLAND RESPONDED BY SAYING HE
JUST RECEIVED DIRT ON
PAUL MANAFORT, WHO WAS
DONALD TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN MANAGER
AT THE TIME FROM "A G.O.P.
FRIEND."
IT WAS ALL A LIE.
ACCORDING TO TODAY'S INDICTMENT,
"DOLAND LATER ACKNOWLEDGED TO
THE FBI HE NEVER MET WITH A
G.O.P. FRIEND IN RELATION TO
THIS INFORMATION HE PASSED TO
DEMCHENKO, BUT RATHER FABRICATED
THE FACT THAT THE MEETING AND
HIS COMMUNICATIONS WITH
DEMCHENKO.
THROUGHOUT 2016, DOLAND AND
OTHER POLITICAL OPERATIVES AND
FED LIES.
THAT ONE OF DEMCHENKO'S SOURCES
BELIEVE THE AID WOULD "TAKE ME
TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT IF
HILLARY WINS."
DEMCHENKO HIMSELF ALSO LIED
ABOUT TRAVELING TO THE MOSCOW
HOTEL IN THE SUMMER OF 2016.
A TRIP WHERE HE SUPPOSEDLY
GATHERED INFORMATION ABOUT THE
INFAMOUS PEE TAPE.
DANCHENKO LIED ABOUT ALL OF THIS
TO THE FBI.
SO THE BIG QUESTION IS, HOW DID
DANCHENKO'S LIES AND ALL OF HIS
BOGUS CONVERSATIONS WITH THESE
SOURCES GET INTO THE
STEELE DOSSIER?
WHO CONNECTED DANCHENKO TO
CHRISTOPHER STEELE?
WELL, THE INDICTMENTS AS A
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL NAMED FIONA HILL FIRST
INTRODUCED DANCHENKO TO STEELE.
IF THAT NAME SOUNDS FAMILIAR IT
IS BECAUSE FIONA HILL WAS ONE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WITNESSES
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP IN HIS
FIRST IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
NOW, SHE HAS POPPED UP AGAIN AS
ONE OF THE KEY FIGURES BEHIND
THE STEELE DOSSIER.
THAT'S EITHER AN INCREDIBLE
COINCIDENCE, OR A SIGN THAT OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY ESTABLISHMENT
IS EVEN MORE CORRUPT THAN WE
THOUGHT IT WAS.
AND IT GETS WORSE.
THE FBI, IT TURNS OUT, KNEW FOR
YEARS THAT DANCHENKO'S SOURCING
WAS GARBAGE.
THEY INCLUDED HIS CLAIMS IN
SEARCH WARRANT APPLICATIONS
AGAINST THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
REGARDLESS, DECLASSIFIED
FOOTNOTES FROM A DOJ
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT
REVEALED THE FBI SUSPECTED
CHRIS STEELE'S DOSSIER WAS PART
OF AN ELABORATE RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
ONE OF THE FOOTNOTES SAID THE
BUREAU "DID NOT HAVE HIGH
CONFIDENCE IN THE SUBSET OF
STEELE'S REPORTING AND ASSESSED
OF THE REFERENCED SUBSET WAS
PART OF A RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN TO DENIGRATE FOREIGN
RELATIONS.
THAT RELATED REFERRED TO FORMER
TRUMP LAWYER MICHAEL COHEN.
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER
COULDN'T FIND ANYTHING TO
SUPPORT THAT CLAIM, AND COHEN
DENIED IT, IT WAS TOTALLY MADE
UP.
TERMS INDICTMENT TODAY MAKES IT
EVEN MORE CLEAR THAT THE FBI
KNEW THE DOSSIER WAS A SCAM.
ACCORDING TO TODAY'S INDICTMENT,
JUNE 2017, FBI AGENTS
INTERVIEWED DANCHENKO IN
VIRGINIA.
AGENTS ASKED DANCHENKO ABOUT HIS
CONTACTS WITH THE CLINTON AIDE
CHARLES DOLAN.
DANCHENKO LIED AND SAID HE DID
NOT TALK TO DOLAN.
THE FBI AGENT DOCUMENTED AT THE
TIME HE KNEW IT WAS A LIE.
BUT NOTHING HAPPENED.
THE FBI DID NOT PROSECUTE
DANCHENKO.
ROBERT MUELLER DIDN'T EVEN
MENTION ANY OF THIS IN HIS
REPORT UNTIL TODAY, UNTIL
JOHN DURHAM'S INDICTMENT.
NO ONE IN THE GOVERNMENT DID A
THING.
NOW DANCHENKO FACES FIVE FEDERAL
CHARGES, INCLUDING LYING TO THE
FBI TO HIDE HIS CONVERSATIONS
WITH DOLAN.
AND THIS COULD JUST BE THE
BEGINNING.
WE ARE LEARNING A LOT ABOUT THE
COLLUSION HOAX VERY QUICKLY.
WEEKS AGO, JOHN DURHAM INDICTED
DNC LAWYER MICHAEL SUSSMANN FOR
LYING TO THE FBI ABOUT A SECRET
CHANNEL OF COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION
AND A RUSSIAN BANK.
DURHAM HAS ALSO SECURED A GUILTY
PLEA FROM AN EX-FBI ATTORNEY WHO
LIED ABOUT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN'S
TIES TO RUSSIA.
NOW, WE ARE LEARNING THAT
HILLARY CLINTON ALLIES GAVE
INFORMATION TO HILLARY CLINTON
CONTRACTOR AND LAUNDERED
ALL OF IT INTO THE FBI AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
MORE THAN FOUR YEARS AFTER THAT
FABRICATED JULY 26TH PHONE CAL